you got a kind face
you got a good head of hair you seem
like a nice guy
I want to help you I'm gonna help you
ReDiscover your manhood Jen are you out
[Music]
amen
from David dear sweet daddy you
frequently mentioned the importance of
marriage and the calling of most people
to marriage I think you're right and I
should get married but a woman who I
could reasonably meet geographically is
not spoken for share similar values and
is herself interested in me seems so
astronomically unlikely as to be
impossible I'm not sure I know anyone
who meets two or three of these criteria
so expecting to find someone who meets
all four just seems unreasonable for
example I'm not sure I know any women at
my church who are single and they seem
to find me repulsive anyway the ladies
in my work will put up with me but
they've all they're all taken and or
Godless Communists anywhere else I'm not
giving a second thought and I feel
invisible the idea of looking for a
potential wife seems like shopping for a
multi-million dollar mansion for when I
win the lottery I don't want to give up
I think I owe it to my parents to give
them a daughter-in-law and grandchildren
and I don't think I'm the only man who
finds himself in this predicament what
do you think well you know you're not
the only man in this predicament
certainly and um I think that every man
I I can't say every but a great number
of men
feel this way at a certain point in
their lives even the ones who end up
married I can remember myself at a time
thinking thinking like you did like the
idea you know because it's all it's it's
not real right now and it's all kind of
in theory and so the idea of finding a
woman who you know who I'm attracted to
and has shares my values and is
attracted to me for some reason uh in
all of those things and and live
somewhere within a vicinity where I can
see this person like the idea of all
that lining up and actually getting
married and starting a family and all
these things
um there was a time in my own life where
that felt it did feel a bit like window
shopping for Mansions uh on the hope
that you'll you know hit a Powerball or
something like that but the good news is
that for
you know I would say probably the
majority of men who feel that way it
does end up happening because as it
turns out you know uh winning a lottery
is it's there's very few people that
ever do that but um a great many adults
end up getting married so it is it is a
it's a normal thing the way you're
feeling right now is normal but what
you're talking about and what you desire
is also normal which means that just
like statistically the odds that it will
happen are great now they're also I get
these kinds of questions and it also
puts me in a tough spot because
um I'm not given important details that
I would need like I have no idea how old
you are I don't know anything about you
other than what you've said here
um and some of that you know it can
change the calculus somewhat so if you
were to tell me that your
single guy never married feeling this
way and you're 55 well I would tell you
that it's not hopeless I mean people
marry later in life so you shouldn't
give up on that by any means it does
make it more difficult I have to admit
now if you're a guy in your early 20s
and you're feeling this way
then it's like you know trust me then I
could I can say with much more
confidence that uh that if you're in
that category that it will work out and
it will be fine and you will because
every you know
almost any guy in the early 20s is going
to feel this way
and if you listen to a lot of women in
their early 20s they feel this way too
I'm never going to find the right guy
all the same what you're talking about
in in the reverse for women great many
women feeling that way the other part of
the good news is that
it is true that a lot of this
is
under your control you I think you have
more control than you realize that you
do or at the very least you'll have a
control over a certain part of it and so
you should focus on controlling those
parts focus on the parts that you can
control
the parts that you can't you know you
you can't you can't make
um the perfect woman materialize at a
thinner you can't do that you can't
control other people if you meet a woman
and she's not the right the right kind
of woman you can't make her into that
then you probably you shouldn't try you
know you can't make a woman into the
kind of woman who you want to marry but
you can make yourself into the kind of
man
that women want to marry buying a new
car can be a stressful experience for
anyone especially if you're a first-time
buyer or if you have no credit before
you walk into a dealership and spend the
entire day with the crowds the stress
the potential to not even find the right
car you need to check out car Zing car
Zing is completely changing the way that
you buy a car online by partnering with
Credit Agencies leaders and over 25 000
dealers Nationwide karzing provides you
with everything you need before stepping
foot into the dealership once you find
the right car at your ideal budget all
you got to do is bring your saved deal
voucher with you to the dealership to
finalize your next ride it is so simple
even if you're not in the market for a
new car you just check out carzing
anyway karzing's online window shopping
experience goes beyond mirror images you
can dive deep into each vehicle's
specifications features and performance
capabilities zoom in on craftsmanship at
the interior Marvel at The Cutting Edge
technology and admire the meticulous
attention to detail that sets these
automobiles apart from the rest karzing
helps make your experience faster
cheaper and less stressful so visit
carzing.com Walsh today and find the
best deals near you that's
carzing.com Walsh now you say that you
are repulsive to women again don't know
anything about you I've never seen you
I think it's very likely that you are
being much harder on yourself than you
ought to be there are repulsive people
out there but they're you know it's it's
uncommon then there are other people
that intentionally try to make
themselves repulsive like the uh the
green-haired people on Tick Tock with
facial piercings and all the rest of it
I assume that's not you so you're
probably being too hard on yourself but
um we can all improve and if you're
still single and you haven't been able
to find a woman and uh you've made
attempts and there are women that you're
interested in they're not interested in
you then you can you can control some
aspects of that you can do things like
you can go to the gym you can get in
really good shape that's going to
improve your your chances significantly
and it's not even because uh women are
shallow and some women are shallow it's
like some men are shallow but the
physical aspect does matter it's the
first thing someone's going to notice
about you and they do have to be
physically attracted to you women aren't
as visual as men are but it still is
important aspect so you can get to the
gym you can get yourself a good shape
you start thinking about you know what
you wear how you present yourself if you
think that your personality is not
attracting the kind of attention that
you want or if you walk into a room and
you you feel invisible and you're not
able to command attention in the room
the way that maybe you see other people
are able to do well that again good news
that that's something that you can
control even your personality you can
change your personality I'm a big
believer in that it's one of the reasons
why I'm you know I've never been a huge
fan of all these personality tests out
there I know there are some that are
supposed to be really scientific and
people really believe in them and you
know there's some validity to it you
know there's kind of a natural sort of
Baseline personality that maybe that we
have that we all have but I think that
it gives people this idea that well
you're a certain personality type and
that's what you are and so you act a
certain way and that's just that's what
it is and you can't change it and I
don't think that's true you know your
personality is there's a lot that goes
into it but a lot of it has to do with
your own behavior like when people
describe your personality they're
talking about how you act and what you
say and how you present yourself
um and the kind of moods that you're in
or at least the kind of moods that you
present to the public that's what other
people are talking about when they
describe your personality and all of
that is controllable you can control all
of that so that's what I would do
um just start thinking about
making yourself if you feel like you're
not desirable to women uh you can change
that so think about all the things make
a mental checklist what are all the
things that you think
a good woman would would find desirable
and
you know if that's a checklist with five
major items let's say
the great news is that about probably
four of those items you can change
immediately there are other things that
might take more time I mean obviously
being financially successful that also
helps because even women who fashion
themselves as independent and
Progressive and enlightened are actually
looking for men who who can provide for
them that's like biologically hardwired
and that's not something that you can
immediately change overnight but it's
also not a necessity either I was not
anywhere close to financially successful
when I got married so those are those
are those are things you could change on
the financial success part of it too I
would also say that
um if you're not rich right now like
that's okay most people aren't and you
can't uh you know I'm not going to give
you some get rich quick quick scheme
where you can go out and be rich in 100
days what you can do though is present
the qualities of someone who a woman
might think well that person yeah they
might not be
super financially successful now but I
could see that they would be in the
future I could see the potential for
that so you can present the qualities of
a hard-working ambitious person with
lots of big ideas and Big Dreams you
know women find that appealing so
that's what I would do uh work on all
that Implement that implement it for
you know a while it's not going to be
overnight fix
and then come back and and we'll see how
you're doing and uh I think that's it
that's only one but we'll we'll leave it
there
[Music]